here's our little red bath for what
we're gonna do with this okay for
starters we're just going to use Excel
we're gonna use the spreadsheet to work
out all of the things have been
calculating it over the little bit
recently expected value variants and
deviation all that but then importantly
what we're gonna do is some analysis of
what happens in we change these aliens
when we muck about with them what we
expect to be the result and then what
the results end up being okay so let's
begin to work out any of these things
down the bottom like standard deviation
for example we need to start with
expected value can someone tell me when
we've got a data set what is the general
process that we go through when working
out expected value it's a bunch of
things to add up right what do we add up
okay what do you reckon in it you can
you can use your book by the way for
this I just want to get your recall on
this okay there's a series of things
that's why we use our Sigma notation
series of things we want to add up well
fantastic that was textbook right take
the variable right you can see a whole
bunch of them here you multiply it by
the chance that it will happen and then
once you've got that you used add all
those up right now when you have a look
at this right there's no frequency table
here so what do you expect
each of these heights that's what these
are how many times do you think each one
comes up exactly once right now if
you've got Excel open like me if you've
got Google sheets or something
comparable it'll look a little different
but what I want you to do is just
highlight all of the piece of data there
if yours is like me mine's actually gone
off the screen here but like just here
underneath mine says count in fact I'll
just make the window a bit smaller so
you can see on there we go
can you guys see right there it says
count and then as a call and it says
nine right so there are nine scores at
the moment nine heights so therefore
what would you think what would you
infer is the probability of each of
these values it's one out of nine right
a knife okay so here's what we're going
to do to get this expected value I want
to take I'm gonna write equals here
because I'm going to start a calculation
now that indicates to your spreadsheet
you wanted to calculate some stuff I
want to add up each of these but each
one multiplied by a ninth do you agree
with that each one of them they all have
the same probability okay so I'm gonna
do is we're going to write that
probability one out of nine okay
is no division button on our keyboard so
we've got to use that slash make sure
it's hanging in the right direction and
then what we multiply that by we don't
again have a multiply symbol so I'm
going to use the asterisk just above the
eight is all of these probabilities
sorry all these values added together
okay now we could just type those in one
point six four plus one point six seven
plus and so on but we don't need to I've
got a spreadsheet so type in the letters
s um for some open a parenthesis like so
and then it says Excel or spreadsheet
saying to you okay well what numbers do
you want the sum off okay what's this PI
carefully look at my mouse cursor right
all I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
highlight I'm gonna hold down the mouse
cursor all the way down and then I'm
gonna let go and you can see that Excel
sort of fills in all of the stuff that I
wanted I'm going to close that bracket
I'm just gonna before I hit enter I'm
just gonna leave that there so you can
see what it looks like and I'm gonna
tell you what it's doing right it's
saying one out of nine that's the
probably of every single one multiplied
by every single one of those values add
it up okay have you hit or not did you
get something one point six five five
six okay now just a quick note if yours
who has exactly that number one point
six five five six exactly that yeah some
people might have more digits the reason
why is if I make my cells a bit wider
here it gives you more decimal places so
it just sort of truncates to be whatever
you've got there and minds a bit smaller
okay so I've got my expected value
question and again if you want to use
your book for this you're welcome to how
do I use the expected value to work out
variance again I'm adding up a bunch of
things what do I add up and I think it's
it's it's quite closely related to the
expected value I'm gonna need the
probability right what I multiply that
by have a think
I'm gonna get this up okay what am i
work here oops
say again don't worry about it too much
for now I'll show you where to find it
but for now just write SD for standard
deviation when I'm working out my
variance right there's a bunch of things
I add up what's gonna fit in here who
remembers our 1a don't I what does that
represent again it's the probability of
each one so I need to know that and then
I have to multiply it sort of like a big
messy thing who remembers this is going
to be in there right that's why we
calculated what's in here
it's that yeah go ahead yep good okay
this guy the actual value I take away
the expected value that's the reason I
calculate it
remember that take away the expected
value and then I actually have to do
something to this whole thing which is I
squared can you remind me again why
we're squaring yeah I'm like I'm not
interested in whether it's positive or
negative I just want to know how much
does it vary how far away is it so the
square gets rid of egative okay so what
we're gonna do is there's my colors here
we're gonna use these cells to do all of
this grunt work for us
okay we're gonna use these cells to do
that so over here let's work out the
thing that needs to get added up for
this one it's gonna be again type equals
to start in equation what's the
probability fit every single one 109 so
I'm gonna write 1 over 9 now I'm
multiplying by let's have a look what's
in here right so first I'm gonna open a
bracket and I say it's the value in this
case it's one point six four take away
the expected value that one point six
whatever okay so I could type those
numbers but I don't have to I'm just
gonna use my curse I'm gonna say whoops
sorry
that's nope let's fix that there if you
click just on that you'll get whatever
that value is even if it changes and
then I'm subtracting the expected value
yeah so I'm just going to tap on to this
cell here and it very helpfully gives us
another color so you can distinguish
what's what right I close the bracket
what was I doing today again I've
written it
the top I'm squaring it we don't have a
square button so what you want is the
it's the Hat which is above the six so
that's symbol there means ^ right and if
we're squaring it's the power of two
like so okay so if I hit enter is this
what your cell tells you does it look
like that with the e and all that kind
of thing yeah does anyone know if no one
knows it's fine but I want to know does
anyone know what that indicates has
anyone seen that before it's very
different to the derivative actually
yeah yeah yeah very good so this e it's
short here it's on your calculator as
well the capital e not the lowercase
this is shorthand for this two point six
eight eight six one times as we'll just
said 10 to the power of whatever number
is on the end there right which in this
case is in negative five what do we call
this kind of notation we call it
scientific notation right science I
think some people call it standard
notation but scientific notation is why
you got scientific calculators it's our
way of representing really really small
numbers or really really massive numbers
yeah so there's just a lot of decimal
places and excels like to forget it I
don't want to write that anymore I'll
just hand it to you like so all right
now what I want to do is I want to take
this and add up for every single value
okay not just for this one I want to do
it for all of these ones down here okay
now the whole idea with Excel is we can
take formulas once you've put the effort
in to craft them you can use them over
and over again don't do what I'm about
to do just watch how I'm gonna do it
I've copied that cell that's why you can
see the ants crawling around and I'm
about to paste it one cell down to try
and get it to do this work for me is
this reasonable looking it shouldn't be
that looks like it's like a crazy value
it doesn't make sense and there's a
reason why if I double-click on this you
can see what's going wrong with my
formula do you see that what's it trying
to do it does probability one over nine
it multiplies by and then it says here's
this value what does it subtract though
yeah this empty cell which is zero right
she'll like this is not what I want it
to do so here's what I want you to do
instead of my error okay can you go back
into this formula you just created okay
what I wanted to do is I want that blue
value to go down as I go down the sheet
I want it to go down to but the red
value b3 I want it to stay put yeah does
that make sense here's the way you do it
put your cursor right in between the B
and the three in that red one there or
whatever color it is for you and come
ask you to put a dollar sign in there
okay that dollar sign means hey hold
still I want you to be locked in
position no matter where you go up and
down it's gonna stay on that press Enter
value hasn't changed but now now I do
want you to do this with me
copy that cell and now let's uh let's
highlight all the way down I want it to
do all these rows and then go ahead and
paste it in okay I'll give you a second
to do that first and then hopefully
these are the values that you get you're
talking about this one here what will
happen is you will get something a
little bit different so I'm just gonna
double click on that so you can see that
well have a look at a sean's is my
suggestion you don't have it yet you
don't have a yeah okay let me put that
there so you can see it it should that's
right if you've typed in your data just
like I have that formula should do it
for you okay all right could I get a
show of hands who's got all these values
and they match mine yep
fantastic okay that sounds really good
well done string around you guys good to
go okay I'll come back to in a second
okay
now the variance is not these individual
numbers what did I have to do again
what's that big Sigma about it means
take the sum add them all up right all
these nine values add all of them up so
where we've got variance here to have an
equal sign
what was that formula I taught you for
how to add stuff up some right so type
in s um open a bracket and then these
things up above these are the things we
want to add yeah so I'm just gonna
highlight all of them loop like so don't
forget to close your bracket I'll just
leave that there for a second so you can
see yours matches mine okay hey mrs.
Lee's thank you all right can I hit
enter did you get zero point zero zero
two seven one three five is it does that
match with you guys
fantastic okay good